okay
woods and mason are going to take point
on this apparently rude nick is lying
low in a remote soviet base in the
mountains of uzbekistan
now vermont enough we're gonna land our
boys nearby and pay my little visit
let's cut this perseus sucker down the
size
rudeness better be in that base if we
came all this [ __ ] way
command sounded confident once we pull
the [ __ ] out of their radio tower and
create a distraction
we'll find out it's time for a little
hide-and-seek
all right we're in position roger that
there's an air mail package ready for
delivery just need an address
go ahead and mark the radio tower for us
basically
coordinates coming your way roger the
check is in the mail
now get down there and eliminate before
you escape
we don't have a lot of time take your
line down
i'll have your back
[Music]
uh
next
got one
oh
[Music]
granada hmm
oh
[Music]
yes
go on and move down
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
get over to the last building
so
[Music]
he's
[Music]
headed out the back
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
uh
uh
[Music]
me
[Music]
we need kill confirmation
for them
i know
mason we can't bring the chopper down
[Music]
it's [ __ ] parade
eyes on smoke touching down soon
hey don't [ __ ] forgive me
nice work down there mate i think percy
is gonna cry like a [ __ ] baby when he
hears me
[Music]
available